what are your
top three biggest threats we're facing
today in america not
worldwide specifically in america if you
were to say number one is this number
two it is number three is this what
would you say it is
i think number one is the fed i think
the i think the fed is gone
off the rails you know they believe
there's no inflation going on
um i think deflation's showing up in the
it has been showing up in the stock
market showing up in real estate i think
it's showing up in things like bitcoin i
mean people are just losing their minds
trying to figure out how they're not
going to lose the value of a dollar
so i think the fed's a big problem i do
think that
the political system's a problem i think
the parties are focused on themselves
not on what the american people want and
i think we've engineered this
system through both the the introduction
of dark money
but also in terms of the way we've
structured the
the voting system the election system
what i'm talking here about is closed
primaries
i'm talking about the fact that if you
don't do what the party says they'll
primary you out the next time so
i think the political system is a big
problem and i think
the um the the unwillingness
of the federal government to really
focus on the things that
matter to uh you know alexander hamilton
understood industrial policy
he understood economic strength he
understood that national security
you know united states security came out
of growing the economic power and
prosperity of the american people
and to do that you had to you had to put
the american people first
industrial policy you know we don't have
to have a centralized economy
but we do have to recognize that other
countries germany
japan china in particular have
industrial policies that are that are
set to erode the economic productivity
of america i think having the government
understand this
and really you know focus on economic
prosperity of americans is
is really the the the third in in our
industrial policy the third
piece of that and so you know financial
i think political and i think economic
uh is our number one two and three uh
problems in this country you think we're
about to have a third party after what
happened with liz cheney and how she
opposed
the republican party has been now
divided into two you think it's going to
turn into something else
or i think they'll eventually unite um
you know i really um you know i really
subscribe to what kathryn gale and
michael porter wrote in the book the
politics industry i think what happened
in alaska in november is going to
is going to happen more i don't think
it's
we're going to have three parties well i
think what's going to happen
is you know particularly what happened
with all the mail-in ballots in in the
in the november elections
where you know state um secretaries
basically
came up and and unilaterally decided to
send out you know massive mail
mail-in ballots i think this the
legislatures are standing back up and
saying
hey no we had a constitution um we had a
state constitution said in our
u.s constitution said this legislature
is supposed to determine voting rules
not
not the executive branch of a state so i
think you're starting to see votes
in that i think you're going to see
people stand up and say look i'm tired
of the parties not doing what i asked so
um
it's not about liz cheney it's about dc
that doesn't work for the people anymore
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye